you went undercover in the capitol hill
autonomous zone and you talk in
quite detail about what it felt like
obviously the last time
that you were in a group like that or
one of the last times you're in a group
like that you were pretty badly beaten
then
developed a little bit of uh ptsd with
regards to being in groups
you said that one of your friends
convinced you that you should go
like how much convincing did it take
from that friend and then can you
tell us about what it was like walking
into
chas blacked up and obviously incredibly
nervous
so after i was beaten in the summer of
2019
which by the way has led to no arrests i
still had had
no justice and that part of that beating
was actually caught on camera
but um that aside um
i did develop an intense fear of
being in public because when i was
beaten it was completely
it started from behind punches
to the head and there was just and i was
in front of essentially the main police
station in downtown so what happened
within eyesight of law enforcement and
it was right by all these courthouses so
it should be an area that is
you would think is safe to walk down in
in the united states
but it wasn't so um
but i fast forward a year later and
all the various therapies that i've had
to address
some of the um cognitive physical
psychological issues of the attack um
the this friend of mine was just um
he was he was encouraging me to go to
chaz because
it was such like a surreal like it was
unbelievable what had happened like we
knew
from looking at the real coverage of
what antifa was saying and putting out
themselves
that this was a territory that they
claimed
um as separate from the us it wasn't
like just this block party that the
president
um claiming it to be so i was like
for me it was i had that fear and i was
like but i had to
deal with it in any way and to go up
because i knew there wouldn't be very
many people who would get the truth out
and um i wore their
uniform and it was very terrifying at
times to be
so scrutinized because just because you
mask up
and look like them that doesn't make you
like just one of them
they're suspicious because they actually
do know they recognize
for example the voice and body movements
of their comrades
so there's somebody in there who's
dressed like one of them but
for example is not participating in
rioting or violence
they question that so i spent five days
five days there and unfortunately on my
last day i was outed
and i had to flee for my life literally
uh from chazz and the sad thing is this
happened right in front of the
uh east police station but it it was an
abandoned station it was
one where rioters had um caused the
whole place to be barricaded up and
police had
completely evacuated from this whole six
block area
in seattle so yeah i spent uh
night time there particularly
well i so i was during the day going to
accommodation elsewhere
and then at night going so you went you
went nocturnal for a week
yes all the interesting all the
interesting stuff happens at night
yeah because that's that's when the the
press would leave
you know the press would only stay there
during the day ben and jerry's who was
giving up free
ice cream couldn't believe that free ice
cream cones
that's right they did that all during
the day at night this is when you would
see
um essentially warlord-like figures
attempting to vie for control over the
area
there was a drug kingpins and stuff like
that right rolling around in open back
trucks
there's people with criminal back known
criminal backgrounds who were going
around with their own
entourage of people who were carrying
weapons yes
[ __ ] so what else did you see on the
night time what did you see that hasn't
been
reported
um fights were breaking out all over
there wasn't unity
in this area at all because you had
essentially uh different buying
ideologies
so there were antsy for there and they
marked their territory all over
with their symbols and graffiti calling
for police to be killed
the blm were more they viewed themselves
as more
along the lines of like revolutionary
marxists
like ones that you saw in the 70s like
black panthers and stuff like that
so they weren't down with want and
property destruction
they didn't think that was useful so
they did it that did cause some
friction and it boiled over as well and
essentially
um antifun won't admit this but
they naturally racially segregated
themselves in there the white people
who were in antifa states
stood um stuck together as a clique
whereas the uh black marxist
they were together in their separate
area so
you know for this area that claimed to
be founded on anti-racism and social
justice there was
racial segregation and then on top of
that they had a 100
black homicide rate 100 black shooting
victim rate
talk to me about how you got discovered
of being andy now
um that is a story that readers should
look for in the book
because i haven't really talked about it
before but i will say
that it involved somebody that i had
written about before um a
transactional antifa militant um
who has a criminal record and has been
i've identified as
being at many riots in the seattle area
and so this individual was really
scrutinizing
my social media to sort of try to
um work out and find out
exactly where i was and all that so
these are and
it wasn't just this individual she was
connected to a whole network of these
online anti-phi activists who are
working to try to identify exactly where
i was
and unfortunately through my own
experience
left certain crumbs that i've learned
to grow from so they become very very
good identifying outsiders it's actually
really scary to go and record their
rides which is why you don't see a lot
of videos coming out now
close up of them like destroying
this businesses and properties um it's
been
independent journalists who have come up
with creative ways to
record because it's so dangerous well
it's not just
that they found you i saw a video on
your youtube
of a guy who looks a little bit like you
walking down the street and everyone's
sticking their fingers up at him
it's so bad that someone that looks like
andy no now is an enemy
of antifa yeah so in portland i was
undercover a lot but they would never
know when i was there when i was not
so i had to change my tactics and come
up with different ways
um and so
they were so overzealous in trying to
track me down and find me
that uh i believe on more than five
locations they misidentified people on
their side
because that person was a male
male of the east asian heritage that
you know just based on sharing the same
race of me they thought was me
uh yeah it's been very embarrassing to
them because
you know they say they're anti-racist
and they just they think that
everything's the most pejorative thing
in the world yeah
every asian male is andy no there's this
bit in that video where the guys stood
in front he's
saying you do realize why you're here
you're
you're being very racist and you're
supposed to be anti-fascists
this is the second time that it's
happened to me at march
and this donkey of a girl stood next to
the person holding the camera
goes well it seems like you're doing it
on purpose and you're like doing what on
purpose being
asian like it seems like you're doing it
on purpose i couldn't believe
[Music]
it
you